uh that's my exorcism face and you saw
it for free without paying ticket price
the devil inside alright so if there is
one thing that we have in abundance its
exorcism movies that are shaky-cam
reality movies or a mixture of both
which is what this is alright so in this
movie this lady freaked out like 1989
and killed a couple people turns out she
was possessed when she did it so now her
daughter's all grown up she's going to
investigate this so now we follow this
chick and a couple of priests on their
exorcism shenanigans which means we get
our fair share of exorcism [ __ ] which is
awesome is what we paid to say and I'll
hand it to this movie the first thing
you hear is the 911 call like possessed
chick talking on the phone it's creepy
as hell I liked it I loved it in fact I
was like good job movie 4 creeping me
out from the get-go love me a good
exorcism movie what can I say so I will
say the positive of this movie if you
want to see some really cool exorcism
stuff you get it in this movie the first
chick you see like her arms all bent
back where she's popping her bones out
of socket and there's like oh so
disturbing and it's so bad for the
actress cuz she's gonna need buddy
plastic surgery that looked er I think
that was real that looked pretty real
not gonna lie there are a few parts in
this movie I was like yep I got the
chills it did it really well if you
watch this movie you see some really
cool exorcisms get freaked out from some
possessed chick this is probably the
movie this movie had the coolest
exorcism element that I've seen in years
it's been a while since I saw an
exorcism movie where I was like yeah
that actually chilled me it's mildly
disturbing it's good job this movie some
of the pacing though ya know after the
nine one one phone call initially creeps
you out it gets you know slow it's a
found footage movie with exorcisms you
know like last exorcism was my complaint
about last exorcism is that I hated the
ending this movie I hate the ending more
yeah I said that why cuz I'm not sure
this movie even has an ending I mean
come on you guys are writing success of
paranormal activity the paranormal
activity audience is coming to you guys
for entertainment in January which is a
nice red flag so the least you can do is
give us a good ending and no not here a
solid enough ending is the kind of thing
that's going to separate the movies that
are a good time no alcohol required from
the movies that you watch when you're
trashed this movie failed in that aspect
so I got to say if you're looking for
some really cool possession action
type stuff this movie does have it it's
really cool when it's cool but when I
like that kind of element in a movie
like this that much in the ending
happens and my brother and I look at
each other we were like well that was
[ __ ] and it totally drops the entire
grade of the movie that is bad so the
movie as a whole is a good time if
you're drunk ya know it's a party don't
care about a cell at any gen movie I
can't feel my face made me sad really
cuz I like these kind of movies collect
racism stuff so your favorite possession
or exorcism movie what is it comment
below let me know it doesn't even have
to have a good ending this this ending
is terrible what's it like without
spoilers I will tell you what it's like
it's kind of like the movie